now there's one more reason that I want
to give you we're gonna you're gonna be
Japan's your headache for this one okay
you remember I hesitated when I was
writing this some quadratic up here
because I wanted to save the quadratic
for another moment I've just established
writs are hard to find it's a very very
hard to find okay but we can still work
with them okay sometimes roots are not
hard to find sometimes roots don't exist
okay now you have a look at this guy
deliberately chosen a really simple one
where you just do this all in your head
right tell me the distributor of this
quadratic well that's why it's negative
3 the discrete is negative 3 so being
that the discriminant is negative 3 it's
less than 0 so when you launch it to
this guy there's the discriminant b
squared minus 4ac you get no real
solutions right so you to graph this
right it's it's positive definite it's
off the axis okay so what we would say
is it doesn't have roots that's all it
said okay except for the fact that well
these results tell you that even though
they aren't roots you can add them right
in this particular situation what's
minus B away it's minus 1 and apparently
we could also know multiply them what's
CLA now this is not just difficult
this is perplexing right how can you add
and multiply things that don't exist and
then get meaningful not even beneath a
button simple numbers out of them have a
look at this right now
this is mysterious this is because we're
saying it exists but we can manipulate
them okay well let's just see what
happens if we follow this to its logical
conclusion right let's just have a plan
right quadratic for you I can do all of
this because I know what a B and C are
right so we're going to get minus B plus
or minus the square root already know if
the discrete is you already told me what
it is it's that all over 2a which is 2
okay no big deal so therefore I have
if the roots will be let's do the
negative case over here and then the
other one should be this now this stage
I would usually pack up and go home okay
but this tells me this tells me there's
something going on yeah so I'm going to
push on it a little bit
okay now extension two students know
exactly how to push on it but even if
your extension one I know how it like I
can add numbers I can multiply not this
I don't know what this thing is but I
know for instance when I'm adding them
something very simple happens right
something very very simple because the
numerate hearing here we already have
language for this back room movie that
says they're conjugates right that one
is plus the negative root three and one
is minus so when you add them or you add
conjugates that plus minus me it just
disappears
yeah it just cancels away so you get
left with nothing at the front you get
minus 1 or 2 plus minus 1 or 2 which is
minus 1 right so even though this thing
doesn't seem to exist it still follows
the rules of arithmetic just like I
should expect it to just like viet is
represented it in exactly the same way
it's a little bit harder but I can work
with the UM I can work with the product
as well okay now this is a big wiener
but again the rules of normal aridity
that i learned back in your 7/8 will
still help me okay let's just multiply
them so i've got the negative case there
and then i have the positive case there
okay and that's all divided by work for
ya because I've got 2 times 2 right so
I'm actually gonna write that 2 times 2
which is 4
okay so now what I have a look at this
it's a little bit weird but it's still
doable
remember we sit there with conjugates
right so this is an a minus B and this
is an A plus B so I can get rid of the
factorization tactics paired with
difference of squares right so here's my
8 right so negative 1 squared and
there's my be the square root of
negative 3 squared all divided by 4 ok
now I know what to do a negative 1 when
you square it you just get what
okay but if this is what it's saying it
is right then when I square it I
shouldn't get three I should get
negative three right I mean that's what
it says it is even though I don't know
how to work with it well when I square
it and get negative three all divided by
four that sure looks like one to me just
like the results told me to predict now
this is part of how they started to get
away from the unavoidable conclusion
that these numbers even though I thought
they were just there's rubbish like when
you look at the when you look at the
graph right there know where of the
graph those numbers there are no roots
right but all of this seems to indicate
to us though these numbers actually they
exist they're just as real as the rest
of them I can do normal arithmetic with
them just like I can yeah well that's
that's a really different question it in
some ways just like over here right a
whole branch of mathematics was
developed to try and answer that
question but all I need to do right now
is those numbers they actually exist I
can do max with them it just loops a way
that negative numbers exist or
irrational numbers exist just because
they don't necessarily fit the rules
that I had before such as I could graph
them on a number line
you can't graph them on a number line
but they are something there they have
an existence that I can work with that
they follow the normal rules unlike say
like say this number right this number
does not exist right it doesn't follow
the normal rules okay some of you know
why but let me show you really quickly
the hearses right why is it that 6
divided by 3 is 2 like on what logic is
it the 6 divided by 3 is 2 very good
in other words 6 is 2 times 3 okay like
this is true because this is true do you
agree with that like the division is
true division gets its definition for
multiplication okay but when you try and
say this right like let's just call it a
number let's give it a name like algebra
says let's give stuff a name even though
I don't know what it is right if this is
true then it follows there should be
some statement equivalent to this which
is that one equals 0
times X but this third number X that can
do that write this number breaks the
rules unlike these numbers which are
weird but they don't break any rules
they work just fine right there are no
inconsistencies here it's there that's
the arm is called the infinite decimal
but it's an area about it's fraught with
problems for this exam so go look up
look up the infinitesimally and easy
ampere and AD and you'll find something
okay
now all that just to establish these
things these things over here they're
freaking awesome okay
like they can work with numbers simply
that are impossible to like calculate or
I've don't even seem to exist in our
world okay but we could still work with
them in very very simple ways okay